I wrote it, I sent it, I'm ****d
- So a couple years
ago, I am hanging out
with a good friend of mine.
I don't want to
use his real name,
so let's just call him...
Taheen.
So Taheen and I are hanging out,
and we decide to (clicks tongue)
you know, light up,
smoke a little J.
(inhaling)
Then Taheen starts getting
a little bit paranoid.
I find this so annoying.
So I decide instead of just
telling Taheen the truth,
I'm gonna text my
best friend, Allie.
And I say, "S.O.S. Tah is
being so annoying, save me!"
I press send and in the
background I hear a ding.
I turn around very
slowly and Taheen goes,
"Is this a joke?"
Protip, don't smoke and text.
Additionally, try to limit
your (bleep) talking.